- [Instructor] Alvaro presses the treadle
of a spinning wheel with his foot.
It moves a bar up and down
making the wheels spin.
So just to be clear what a treadle is
this is an old spinning wheel
and this little pedal that is a treadle.
And as this goes up and down,
it's gonna pull on this bar,
which is then going to spin this wheel
which can then be used to
essentially power the machine.
So it says the function B of t
models the height in centimeters
of the top of the bar
when Alvaro has pressed
the treadle for t seconds.
So it's telling us the height of,
I can barely see where
the top of the bar is
someplace over here.
And this isn't exactly
what they're probably talking
about in this exercise here.
But this is just to
give you a visualization
of what a treadle is and what the bar is
and then, what the spinning wheel is.
Alvaro has pressed those
treadle for t seconds.
So they give us B of t right over here
and 90 minus 12 times sine of 5t.
The first question is,
what does the solution set to y is equal
to 90 minus 12 times sine of
five times six, represent?
Pause this video and see if
you can think about that.
All right.
So, it looks like right over here,
so we have the 90, 90, 12, 12
and we're subtracting 12 sine
of five times t, five times t.
So this right over here is t.
The solution set right over here tells us
what is the height, because
that's what B of t is.
So B of t is equal to y.
What is the height when t is equal to six?
And remember, t is in seconds.
So, this is height,
height of top of bar,
top of bar at six seconds.
All right, now we have
more questions here.
The next question asks us,
what does the solution set to 95
equals 90 minus 12 sign of 5t represent?
Pause the video and think about that.
All right.
So here, they're saying
that B of t is equal to 95.
And so, the solution set,
you're really solving for t.
So you're really solving
for all of the times
when our height is going
to be 95 centimeters.
So all times t
when height of top of bar,
of top of bar
at 95 centimeters.
And that's going to keep happening
over and over and over again
as t goes forward in time.
So you're going to have a very large,
you're gonna have an infinite
solution set over here.
You're gonna have an
infinite number of t's
at which your solution at
which the top of the bar
is at 95 centimeters.
Now we have another question.
This one is asking us,
what does the solution set
to y is equal to 90 minus 12 sine
of pi over two represent?
So pause the video and think about that.
All right, now this is pretty interesting.
We can actually evaluate
what sine of pi over two is.
So sign of pi over two
radians or sign of 90 degrees
that is going to be equal to one.
And so, that's the maximum value
that this sign over here can take on.
Now, we're going to
subtract 12 times that.
So this is taking on a max.
Then when you subtract 12 times that
this is actually the minimum
value that you can take on.
You're gonna have, you can't
get any lower than this.
And so, this is going to be
the lowest, the lowest height
for the top of the bar.
And we're done.